the hardest task in getting any deal
across the line in Northern Ireland will
of course be getting the different
communities and parties to agree and
then to get back to the Stormont
assembly
the toughest nut to crack in this is the
leading unionist party the dup which
says there must be fundamental change
and they won't rejoin power sharing
until their requirements are met
other parties have been deeply critical
of that approach across Community
Alliance party amongst them and its
leader Naomi long joins me now live from
Belfast
good morning Miss Long
good morning
now you met with the Prime Minister this
week despite the fact that I got they
sent the your invitation to the wrong
place uh you did eventually manage to
get together
um did you come away from that thinking
that a deal could be done
well I mean I think the Prime Minister
certainly was reassuring in the sense
that he was speaking positively
um about how the negotiations were going
but he was also realistic about the fact
that there was a lot of work to do and
in Northern Ireland we perhaps better
than anywhere else understand that you
can be 95 of the way to a deal but it's
the last five percent that is often the
hardest bit to finish so near but it's
still very far I think on teledeal is
over the line until it's agreed we we
really won't know
um the final outcome but from our
perspective we wanted to communicate to
the Prime Minister the importance of
listening to all of the parties in
Northern Ireland and recognizing that
over 70 percent of people in Northern
Ireland support
um remaining within the single Market
want to have dual Market access and that
that is the bottom line irrespective of
the dep's tests that is the bottom line
for the majority of people in Northern
Ireland
in that final five percent that you
referred to
who and what is in that box do you think
who what where are the final obstacles
well I mean I think that there are some
of the issues I mean I was listening to
Lord mandelson and I think he very
clearly said like for example the issue
around a democratic deficit the need for
the EU to engage with Northern Ireland
parties I have to say the EU have been
very willing to do that in fact they
wanted to set up a new office in Belfast
where they could do that and it was the
British government that stood in the way
I thought and objected so I hope that
that will be dealt with as part of the
discussions but also I think issues
around for example the jurisdiction
um of the European court of justice is
likely to be one of the sticking points
in order to remain part of the single
Market there are certain things that we
have to adapt to in Northern Ireland one
of those is around where the final Point
um of decision making on disputes will
be I mean this is a fairly um high level
discussion unionism treated as though it
is a constitutional issue I think most
businesses I think most people
um treat it as though it is a pragmatic
um a pragmatic solution to a problem
that needs to be resolved if there are
disputes trade disputes or other
disputes between Northern Ireland
companies and those in the rest of the
EU there has to be a court that has
jurisdiction in both in order to be able
to resolve those but I'm a pragmatist in
this if the EU can find a solution to
this intractable problem along with the
UK government then I think that's
something we would all welcome but I
wouldn't want it to be blown out of
proportion the reality here is that no
business in Northern Ireland has been
coming to me in a cold sweat worried
about the jurisdiction of the ecj what
they're worried about is their ability
to continue to trade into both markets
and then to exploit that dual Market
access in order to grow our economy and
bring prosperity to the people of
Northern and Ireland is your is it your
point that um
an economic or trade problem and a
practical problem is being turned into a
constitutional issue and doesn't need to
um I know that you told my colleague
Sophie Ridge on this program previously
that the dup are holding the people of
Northern Ireland to Ransom is that what
you mean
well I mean both I think first of all
these are not constitutional issues in
the Good Friday agreement was set out
very clearly High the Constitutional
possession of Northern Ireland would be
changed it would only be with the
express consent and will of those who
live here and that has not happened
there has been no referendum on that so
we remain part of the United Kingdom and
unionism should be secure in that I
think in terms of holding the holding
the people of Northern Ireland to Ransom
absolutely that is the case the dup
walked away from functioning
institutions they have left us without a
government and now without ministers and
so we are in a rather ship essentially
on pretty choppy Waters when it comes to
the economic and financial situation
facing Northern Ireland so I mean this
we have no we have no leverage if you
like in the debate with the EU and the
UK other than the persuasiveness of our
argument but I think it's wrong to
collapse the institutions there is no
good reason and why we could not have
functioning institutions and as an
executive collectively speak to the UK
government about what the majority of
people in Northern Ireland want about
the concerns we have around the
heavy-handed bureaucracy of the protocol
and at the same time be able to move
forward with the pragmatic politics that
needs to be done in terms of reforming
our Health Service delivering education
and improving our justice system
well in a way that takes us all takes me
on to an underlying question I I wanted
to ask you to address the
Arrangements uh for democracy in
Northern Ireland are really ruled by The
Good Friday agreement now we've had two
lengthy periods where essentially there
has been no devolved government one
because Sinn Fein wouldn't sit once
because the dup won't sit but though
they're able to achieve that outcome
because of those arrangements under the
Good Friday agreement is it your view
that at some point soon
we're going to have to reconsider
whether that is the best way to Run
Northern Ireland's Administration
well I think that the principles of the
Good Friday agreement of inclusion um of
equality and a fairness of working
together is the right and is are still
the right principles and I've stood the
test at the time over the last 25 years
however I think that the as it's been
described the ugly architecture of our
structures and institutions here which
have embedded sectarianism and Division
I think do need to be reviewed my own
party's growth is evidence that this is
not a binary Community you're not either
unionist or nationalist there are lots
of people who are unionist nationalists
and many other things as well so from
our perspective we think that a review
of The Good Friday agreement structures
is long overdue we need to do that in
order to ensure that we have stable
government you've referred to two
lengthy periods um of suspension we've
actually had now three lengthy periods
of suspension plus a number of other
very unstable periods in the last 25
years and I think when something isn't
delivering what it said it would in
strong one paragraph one which was
stable devolved government for Northern
Ireland then we have to go back to the
drawing board with the institutions and
look at what can be improved we have put
forward fairly modest proposals in terms
of how those structures could work
better in order that parties could be
still based on their mandate part of
government but if they choose to opt out
they can't prevent government continuing
and I think very few would opt out if
they thought government would go on
without them they opt out because they
know that it brings everything to Halt
and I think the government irrespective
of whether a deal is able to be achieved
with the EU that satisfies the dup's
current demands I think the government
needs to do that reform of the
institutions because inevitably there
will be other political problems that
emerge down the line which to
destabilize it in the future okay Naomi
long thank you so much I know that we'll
return to that in due course but thank
you